a changing of the guard in Malaysia that
critics are calling the death of
democracy
Moya Dean Yasin swearing in as Prime
Minister capping a tumultuous week in
the country's politics the king announce
Maya Dean's appointment on Saturday in a
move that sidelined former leader Maha
tear Muhammad whose ruling coalition
collapsed last week
mahoto resigned as premier after his
bizarre - party which is led by mayor
Dean signaled it could work with the
United Malays national organization or
aam know that party government for more
than 60 years until it was forced from
power by Maha tears coalition in 2018 um
now is the party of disgraced former
leader Najib Razak who's on trial for
corruption accused of looting millions
of dollars from the state fund 1mdb
Mohideen was kicked out of ummno in 2015
but it rallied behind him this week he
was sacked for raising the issues of
corruption or 1mdb but now in the sort
of elite wrangling that's happened in
the last week or so in Malaysia he's
joined forces with the same person in
the same party that he was sacked from
and issues he stood up for before now he
seems to be making alliances with many
believe the latest crisis was also part
of a tussle for power between Mahathir
Mohamad and his longtime rival Anwar
Ibrahim analysts say their coalition was
torn apart by infighting over who should
succeed Maha tere who at 94 was the
world's oldest premier earlier on
Saturday anwar said he'd back maha tears
returned to power but now neither man is
leader and there are calls for protests
Maha tere boycotted the swearing-in
ceremony and is determined to fight back
saying he has more support to lead
Victoria Gaytan be al-jazeera